here we go in five four three two one
good morning good evening hello you
smelly smelly cross-eyed gap-toothed
[ __ ]
but the [ __ ] Mike next year face it
this is fine man I'm so sick of your
[ __ ]
but the [ __ ] might next year face
whatever dude good morning everybody -
welcome to the genius project I'd start
I hope your host David so and I am your
other co-host George it's okawa and
again we have nicked the ear today we
had a very very great treat we just saw
[ __ ] dick put on a clinic he just
[ __ ] just smack people up tonight was
his opponent six feet six he Alam six
one so Jason asked me like 6-2 6-3 the
interesting thing is like me and Nick
well Nick is a little bit taller than me
I think yeah um but when I see him fight
in a bar I'm like that's what I should
be you guys are all full of [ __ ] none of
this ever happened
I got beat up but today by Jason Jason
[ __ ] broke my toe let's talk about
you broke your toe - yeah no on his
[ __ ] elbow I kicked his elbow and I
hurt so bad dude that's why Sean
O'Malley do with Andre sukham taught a
piece you guys a [ __ ] minute the [ __ ]
that every time I do a podcast somebody
always gets arrested they wait for the
minute that genius brain starts so I had
a heart attack dude it's always in
Glendale - what the [ __ ] is happening in
Glendale the Armenian mob is getting
kind of loose loose it was Armenian
basketball game just got out of hand
no [ __ ] no my family you know you met my
cousin Greg and then the kids right we
we said we paired up with an Armenian
family and we we played a game of
pick-up yeah
dude and it was it was funny because
there was like a match for every like
family member like two boys and in a guy
like that's like in his mid-20s like me
and then like the dad yeah and then like
we all played a game four on four or
what was it yeah five four four yeah
yeah yeah
it was so funny because like we're just
playing a friendly game and the dad was
like hell a military style and like when
things started like when they started
losing they were just like getting on
each other's case and arguing and all
that and I was like damn dude it's such
an aggressive culture dude god I don't
know if it's like a stereotype or
anything but I've been living in
Glendale now for about what thirty four
months and if it's a stereotype it's
highly accurate because okay so I have a
girlfriend and I just kind of was
venting to him I like bro what's with
jerk you Armenian people make Korean
people look like Japanese people like
why the [ __ ] is everybody so [ __ ]
aggressive and they weren't mean to us
or anything like that but they were just
intense yeah like the dad was like I
told you to make the shot make like they
felt like everybody was getting in
trouble with each other yeah
like the sons were yelling at the dad
and the dad was just like yeah I don't
know if he was just saying it to make me
laugh but he goes you know what bro is
like everybody can get it that's not
because you're just somebody goes just
Armenian men just have this like type of
male aggression yeah I think he goes
they talk to their kids like that they
talk to everybody like that so just
don't take it personal it's a tough
culture yeah and then so like at the end
I was like damn dude do we do we piss
them off or something and then like
afterwards they're like good game bro
yeah good game bro I'm going to kill my
kids later baby I'm too sensitive to
hang out with that I'd [ __ ] I'd lose
it dude I start crying if if I had an
Armenian dude on my team I think you
beat them up no I wouldn't think we so
play with a bunch of Armenian dudes in a
basketball league and they were always
yelling at each other other people too
but like at each other you're like yeah
no but that's all I just pictured like
an Armenian basketball league which is
really strong looking dudes playing ball
with a cigarette in their mouth so how
do you smokey and playing basketball we
used to play water and I played water
polo in high school which is like kinda
lame but when we played water polo
player games at Glendale High School
yeah and all the guys on their team
looked like [ __ ] man dude they were
all hair they all like middle-aged dudes
and they're all beasts we play against
them play against Hoover
and like I was at in high school I was
like 125 maybe yeah like soaking wet
literally soaking wet 125 she's not no
hair on my body at all no pubes nothing
just just armpit hair dude one whisk at
these [ __ ] guys when I would like
play D on them I was like I'm not doing
anything to these guys yeah they could
literally pick me up out of the water
and throw me off the pool as they're so
[ __ ] when you play water polo you
can't touch the ground no useful usually
the pool is like is like 12 feet deep so
you gotta tread water damn that's some
crazy [ __ ] yeah dude in my karate club I
have this kid he's Armenian and he has a
thicker mustache from me right and I in
my head he's 17 so I'm like when are you
going to karate camp so like the the age
that you're allowed to go is like from
16 on and you got to sign a waiver and
stuff like that right yeah he goes oh I
can't go yet and I'm like oh your
parents won't sign your waiver and he
goes no it's because I'm only 13 oh I'm
like wait 13 does that mean you're like
in eighth grade yeah and he's like yeah
I'm gonna graduate this this year what
thought I'm like you're 13 how can you
have a thicker mustache 13 I have to
pick up my kids later so that's [ __ ]
crazy I know I mean he looked like and
he's tall too like he's taller than me
already so I'm like oh yeah he's
probably like 17 18 or whatever some
some cultures are just built differently
they just have is this [ __ ] thing
about them dude I for sure know within
my lineage if you go a hundred years
back definitely a makeup artist and a
fairy
that's like to my bones are so [ __ ]
frail dude I feel like when we spar with
certain people like especially like
bigger black dudes a child
they're so [ __ ] yeah that's the thing
is like when I learn when I first time
people be like my buddy Kenny would
always tell me like training what black
people are different like they just move
different they hit harder like they're
really explosive and I always would be
like yeah whatever you know I didn't
really think
of it and then we spotted Whittle we
smart with Eliot I murder like Eliot
would train with us a lot more
frequently and this dude is like a DTD
to d1 college football athlete like just
you know top of the line genetics you
know and this dude he would hit me and
it I didn't like literally didn't know
who the [ __ ] hit me I literally look and
be like what the [ __ ] is going on I
couldn't track how fast he was and he
would just beat the [ __ ] out of me he
would literally toss me across the room
when we would do jiu-jitsu he would
[ __ ] destroy me all the time
just cuz he was so fast so athletic so
strong and there was nothing I couldn't
do I just had to take it I had to just
take you to him I'm just getting beat up
by this dude for years I mean it makes
sense I mean look who's dominating
athletics yeah you know it's it's it's
not Japanese dominating who's dominating
[ __ ] ping-pong badminton in chess
yeah [ __ ] Chinese people how private
life people that you take every sport
away from this I'm gonna be so [ __ ]
upset give us something dude
they're they're only gonna play sports
that get you [ __ ] though and those
sports don't get you [ __ ] so they're
like nah get you mad [ __ ] yeah you're
right or you swing so hard it just goes
is really fun that's a sport I've played
where I didn't think I'd enjoy and I
played it and I was like you're blood
bro I know I was like I'm pretty good at
this scene here [ __ ] blood
like what I'm really good I'm really
good at this they asked me to be on the
college team but I was like not a lot of
older Asian men play badminton [ __ ]
furiously sure we gonna team together
the badminton team that's another sport
I have to learn that's too hard man bad
dude badminton is pretty like straight
for why not just tennis for tennis is
hard hard yeah it is hard my sister
played tennis she was really good the
whole family played tennis you never did
it
otherwise I'd always hit it over the
fence it would be like make it the [ __ ]
outta you
we never loved you it's just ten assists
a [ __ ] anyway so let's get into the
topic today all right topic of the day
go to the guy this is an interesting one
baby can I ask you a question is my dick
big enough that's like absolutely not
and you will never be loved yo and we
did ask what
feels I would get 30% of the questions
was always is my dick big enough man how
old are they they sound like they're
they're in their teens oh that's why I'm
yeah I can do guys just [ __ ] don't
worry about your dick so much
it's like worry about the fact that you
smell like [ __ ] how about that shower
first I'm 26 and I still worry about my
dick why Nick just cuz it's like so
small it's have you seen those batteries
inside as a laser pointer that's what it
is erect it's just all right there just
sits on top of each other like two pedis
two pens back so the question is well
they didn't say if we could mention
their name so I won't but hey David do
you have videos where you talk about
working out anger issues I know you
explained you at anger issues in the
past I did Joe my brother as of late has
too and I want to come to understand him
in the past bro I still have anger like
uh you know I heard in the past you you
had to get over your man anger issues is
like us for our life soul I think
especially like I think in Asian culture
we have this tendency to bottle up a lot
of [ __ ] and blow up right yeah and I'm
sure that this happens in a lot of other
cultures but the level of violence that
we express when it's mutated into this
really toxic like anger issue that Asian
men have it's like psycho level yeah and
I've heard it from other cultures too
only because I've dated like in mixed
relationships and things like that and
how like you know they said that they
never really grew up in this violent
environment mm-hm even for my friends
that are non Asian like they they Dave
and Dave some of them got like spanked
and stuff like that but that level of
rage that I was explaining to him they
there were like whoa that's just weird
that's like there's that's like abusive
if you if you did that in the US you'd
go to jail yeah I feel like white people
family rage is either goes into I say
white people doesn't like white America
from what I've seen just growing up with
white people I think it's not growing up
just hearing these stories they've
they're they're what they considered
rage is abuse but that's just everyday
Japanese Korean life
no you're right yeah you know what
though my like I had friends like white
friends growing up they were kind of
like white trash right like you know
like their family owned junkyards and
all that and that's not to say that all
all of them are the same buddy that was
my introduction what about you know
right but that was my introduction to
white culture
yeah I didn't know middle-class white
people I didn't know like rich white
people yeah so their dads were pretty
crazy like good I thought that was
normal but what I never saw was them
beating their kids the way that Asian
dads would do it hmm
so like they would yell they would cuss
dude I remember like I was my friend's
dad had a truck washing service yeah and
this guy would snap a lot so I would be
terrified and I'd shake around him but
um one day like oh I think I was like in
junior high or whatever but one day we
were in his truck and then he was trying
to get this thing under my buddy so dad
was sitting in the driver's seat my
friends in the middle and I'm on the I'm
on the right side right so it's a truck
we could all sit in one little thing
together and and he's trying to like put
this box in the middle and then he's
like spiritual [ __ ] legs like a [ __ ]
and move them I was like 13 cuz we were
in junior high - like and then so like I
would go with them to the truck would
like we would go wash trucks and a new
paint and I'm like ride your [ __ ]
legs like the queues and move up he was
that's a lot of context in that
reference yeah he would he would explode
but I never seen him [ __ ] spank him
and I was like dude you don't get hit by
your dad or nothing and he's like nah so
like so give me that all day he just
calls me a piece of [ __ ] every time yeah
that's it though but his his intensity
was crazily yes or too much yeah and
then like you know there were other
white kids that got like spanked from
here and there but like not like the
level of abuse but I mean abuse exists
in all cultures you know you have your
alcoholic dads that come home beat the
[ __ ] out of em like that [ __ ] happens
yeah like it's not specific to one
culture but I think the acceptance in
how common it is for especially Japanese
and
Koreans it's just a different level yeah
yeah dude my mom is to find [ __ ]
anything to hit me with and it's both
parents - yeah TAC team dude WFC like if
I really [ __ ] up and my dad would be
Mia like not beat me up a like he would
spanking me but my mom would be the one
to [ __ ] your mom so gentle though
dude she's too [ __ ] what me but I
said deserve it dude I was a little
[ __ ] but apparently and of course my
sisters will always be like they're
older than me they'd always be like oh
you didn't see anything we got the we
got we got beat away more than you which
is probably true but man I still get
[ __ ] beat I see it spank but I think
it made me a better person though it
taught me like there you're a better
fighter from it yeah
amateur matches from your mom yeah I
just see my mom across the ring oh my
god [ __ ] see that's why I see you my
[ __ ] opponent dude my um so I I was
dating this Korean girl at one point
right and then oh god we went to go
already
oh we went to go to the pier yeah like
and in Jeddah curfew and then we lost
track of time and I was like oh [ __ ]
like we got to go home so we went home
and then um her mom opened the door she
was all smiling and [ __ ] and I'm like
I'm sorry you know so late like I'm
really sorry and then like she was like
it's cool you know whatever and then she
uh oh so don't worry so basically yeah I
leave right and then I get a call later
and she's crying she's like my both my
parents beat me so hard I'm like what
happened and then she's like are you
okay like Joe are you talking to me like
that
are you doing a bit
[Laughter]
hey what the was a good lane back so she
tells me as soon like she thought it was
cool because her mom was smiling and
Sharon it was all good right as soon as
the [ __ ] door closed right my dad was
behind the door hiding and that
[ __ ] Taekwondo kicked her in the
stomach oh that makes sense
so the door closed the Taekwondo kicked
her on his stomach right her she fell
down her mom went literally like behind
her popped her in the head and then they
both jumped her yeah dude
they tag-team [ __ ] jumped her yeah I
was like god what that's [ __ ] Korea
I've never had a tag team jump I will
tell you this though not my boy that is
still a sign of a very healthy
relationship because the parents are
always on each other side they did it
together and get it together because my
parents beat my ass too because it
wasn't because you know they were a WWE
[ __ ] a team dude w/e team they would
because you know how they would they
laugh and [ __ ] Oh have her [ __ ] pink
and purple span next thing she come in
jump off the stomach to make sure you
don't get up yeah my itchy with the 3ds
they would you would always hear people
say [ __ ] like their parents would be
like just wait till your father gets
home
but that's only after my mom first beat
me yeah that would come and then both
and would beat my ass oh sure it was it
was never wait till your daddy's home
meaning I'm not that doesn't mean that I
got saved from the first beating it just
means that beings gonna happen and then
you get your ass beat again yeah so they
were a very strong front so they taught
me what a healthy relationship is so
they would beat my ass dude I used to
get beat three times in one day David is
like a head kick his [ __ ] kid and
maritals gonna [ __ ] a piledriver
we're gonna do some [ __ ] straight-up
what you call that [ __ ] the hardy boy
party I just jump off the turnbuckle and
[ __ ] do a swan Tom yeah
your friend runs up you grab them throw
them and throw them in the air [ __ ]
slap and [ __ ] just gonna be tight dude
you're gonna powerbomb your kids and ya
boost them up table Superman
I want my kids to mess up just like a
[ __ ] them up and with a sweet chin music
boom this podcast is brought to you by
Skillshare my friends man if you have
not heard of Skillshare you are missing
out because I'm all about lifelong
learning I'm talking about learning
stuff for the rest of your life outside
of just the regular school curriculum
I'm talking about learning my friends
where you're learning things that you
want to learn it could be a hobby it
could be anything from like productivity
all the way to video editing to music
whatever whatever you can think of man
Skillshare has got it because we're
talking about a library full of
knowledge and courses for you to take at
your leisure and at your pace because
learning my friends is all about fun and
skill share for me anyways makes it fun
because I get to learn in my own pace
right now I'm going through video
editing because I am dull with those
skills and skill she has been helping me
out with that because I've been taking a
lot of those courses and specifically
how to use Adobe Premiere I absolutely
absolutely love it so check it out guys
join the millions of students already
learning on Skillshare today with a
special offer just for my listeners get
two months of Skillshare for free that's
right Skillshare is offering genius
brain listeners two months of unlimited
access to thousands of classes for free
to sign up go to Skillshare calm flash
brain again go to Skillshare calm slash
brain to start your two months now that
Skillshare calm slash brain dude for it
so so like this crazy IRA bucky i
repressed a lot of memory right so i
don't remember a lot of [ __ ] so i have a
lot of like positive feelings among my
grandma and all this [ __ ] right and then
one day my brother my mom was telling me
this was like couple years back and and
she's like did you know that like i
would come home and your grandma is like
riding you like a horse but like the
other way and slapping your [ __ ]
[ __ ] you don't remember that i don't
[ __ ] remember that and she's like
because he was looking the other way
she's like we used to beat you like
three times so like first your grandma
like you would catch you do some [ __ ]
and then she's [ __ ] your ass up right
and then afterwards your dad comes home
and then she tells him
and he [ __ ] your ass up and then when I
come home I get mad and everyone like
there's mad people [ __ ] you up and
I'm like oh my god I only remember who
let dude yeah I don't [ __ ] remember
that she goes yeah she's like we [ __ ]
up I'm like oh [ __ ] that makes it only
need one beating yeah yeah one doesn't
reinforce anything yeah you forget about
why you're even getting beat up yeah
you're getting beat at that point I'm
I'm at one time my mom beat my ass so
bad because I [ __ ] deserved it this
is this is what I used to do when I was
a kid I used to think I was [ __ ] so
smart I don't know how old I was but I
think I would outsmart everybody but I
wasn't ever but I think my mom my
grandparents lived in the back house and
my mom was like hey bring this to your
grand grandfather and I was like ok I
will but I just didn't want to do it I
was like [ __ ] I was like having a fit so
I brought it over to her but to him I
came back and my mom goes hey so uh
how'd it go everything cool and he goes
and I tell her I look at her and I go
yeah but you know what he said she goes
what and I go he said you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] like I don't know how old I was
dude oh my god yeah I don't know what
did I turn them against each other and I
was like yeah like he said you're a
[ __ ] like that's so crazy like I don't
know like I literally was like I don't
know why he said that she goes what what
do you say and I was like yeah that's
that's what he said I don't even I don't
even know about your evil child to ever
beat the brakes off me dude she [ __ ]
she knew you were [ __ ] trying to male
new bro she was like he would never say
that yeah he would be he barely spoke
you need to speak that much English yeah
and he [ __ ] [ __ ] is not in his book
on Drude per said you are not that smart
dude dude she looked at me she was like
oh he said that huh and I was like yeah
in my head I'm like oh [ __ ] working I
was like yeah he did say I don't know
why he said you're so crazy you don't
even know how to sell quantum physics oh
yeah he doesn't speak any English
quantum physics dude I put some [ __ ]
like that but it actually worked when I
think back dude it's really [ __ ] up
so this jomama story is right here yeah
yeah so like what happened man but I
remember my mom pissed me off right and
then she was in the kitchen preparing
some snacks we had a guest over
and he was like talking to my dad and
then I walked out in a living room and I
said mom mom doesn't want you here she's
just pretending to like you and I walked
away
and then that guy I heard my dad go I am
so sorry and then my mom says I didn't
say that and then the guest was like so
embarrassed and he was like oh [ __ ] and
then he basically like pretty much was
like putting on his shoes getting up and
they're like no please stay please stay
like this is like no we're sorry we're
sorry and then I was like [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] I got [ __ ] up so hard
dude was it worth it it was worth it
because I don't know what at what I
remember feeling like I got you [ __ ]
but I still got [ __ ] up I don't care I
[ __ ] hated that guy too so the guy
captain of a ship like anything took us
to yet about he like he like made
hamburgers for us and I just got him I
liked him a lot
yeah why are you getting your ass beat
you're just looking like staring off to
the distance like yeah I [ __ ] got
that good and I begged my dad to like
ask him to take me on a boat ride and
you like you [ __ ] idiot like he's not
gonna wanna he doesn't want to come
around anymore he [ __ ] hates you dude
I was like oh man like I really I don't
know how I've ever done something so
[ __ ] stupid that your parents just
laugh that you would never beat you so
once when I was a kid I saw the [ __ ] in
the [ __ ] cartoon or some kind of TV
show I don't know where I got it from
but basically I knew I was gonna get my
ass beat so I knew that there was a
phone book inside my parents bathroom so
I ran into the bathroom and I grabbed
the phone book and I opened it up and I
put around my ass cheeks I put my pants
and my boxers over at my I was like 5
you could hit me
my dad just saw this huge phone book in
my pants oh my god he's in tears
laughing and he just called me a [ __ ]
in Korean it tells me to go to my room
I don't know what hurt more I would have
yeah I think he was just dying laughing
then he calls my mom over and then my
mom's laughing her ass off I don't know
what hurt more than laughing at me or I
thought it was cute yeah he's trying to
like not [ __ ] you know his brain that
we didn't think he had yeah it didn't
work the second time because the second
time I tried that [ __ ] they took the
book out they smacked my head with a
beat you the phone book but I guess like
if she's asking if her how to deal with
her brother's rage I mean you can't
really deal with somebody else's rage
for them it comes like this weird point
where they have to realize a damnit they
have to yeah cuz for for me it was so
normal I never knew it was a problem
until I had somebody close to me tell me
how much it affected them and I got to
see how people solve their problems
without getting angry without breaking
[ __ ] without screaming and I think to
myself okay well is that normal like I
guess that's how you deal with your
anger you don't have to just break a
iphone over somebody's face yeah maybe
yeah definitely there's different levels
of anger too because you know I never
realized it was a word called verbal
abuse I thought that was some [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah cuz I'm soft I'm like the only type
of abuse that I understand is a torture
physical and like torture manipulative
like mental like that drama abuse yeah
right and we're like its it's like that
[ __ ] like what is that movie like
when the Mean Girls and [ __ ] that's what
I try to do to my mom and my grandma
then calling somebody a [ __ ] or
whatever I didn't think that was a form
of abuse yeah but it actually is because
it hurts right and it you're throwing
this negative energy aggressive energy
and then now I'm at the understanding
that even being aggressive and throwing
aggressive vibes in the air is also a
form of like abuse because people feel
it and then they get uncomfortable and
they feel scared
mmm-hmm because like I used to think
like violence isn't real violence until
you beat the [ __ ] out of somebody yeah
you know but if I was being called out
for being violent I'm like how I didn't
break anything I didn't hurt nobody like
how am I being violent you're a [ __ ]
lying sack of [ __ ]
yeah we're verbal abuse I feel -
especially at a younger
age that thing sticks so [ __ ] hard
you wouldn't even believe it cuz a lot
of the times that I'm finding out - some
of the things that you know our friends
that you you won't see somebody getting
arrested yup man someone's being violent
somebody cut off some Armenian dude you
smack the [ __ ] out of them yeah we're
finding out - as we get older and we try
feel like when we're at a young age we
were always in denial of these things
yeah what are you talking about like
that's I'm fine nothing really affects
me like I just I just [ __ ] brushed it
off but you'll see these in your
behaviors as you get older so probably
for this person's brother well what
happened I'm saying it it could be a
possibility but how did how does your
family deal with rage yeah that where
did he get it from your dad to get it
from how their parents do conflict
resolution there's there's a there's a
reason for why these things happen and
so for you you can't solve your
brother's rage and the only thing that
you have to understand right now is that
he even he doesn't understand it yeah
but it helps to talk to him when he's in
a calm state yeah
you can't talk to him when he's in his
rage episode when he's the Incredible
Hulk and and he's just in his zone like
you gotta calm him down until you know
he's the chill human being yeah because
I think when we try to talk to people
especially when we fight with our
significant others we always try to have
the deepest conversation while
everybody's bad doing that [ __ ] man it's
just got to cool off cuz got a letter
I'm just gonna say nonsense you gotta
give them their space yeah it's your ego
just constantly trying to win yeah
and it's holding on to the little pride
that it has left yeah the the pride part
is very hard to move on when you are
sucked up into your emotions because
that's the first thing you're always
trying to protect it's not about how do
we solve this it's about who's right you
know I'm right and I want to prove to
you that I'm right so you could feel
dumb
yeah and that's the part where things
just start to blow up and go out of
control because I'll find out to where I
look back now where Muriel and I were
fighting about [ __ ] and then at the end
of the day we're not even fighting about
or arguing points that have to do with
the original argument now we're just
saying okay well you said this well you
said that and then we say what are we
fighting about are fighting over grammar
yeah we're study buddies by the way you
didn't add a [ __ ] period so I didn't
understand
we don't know where the arguments going
cuz now we're just trying to hurt each
other that's all we're trying to do I'm
right you're wrong
Yeah right you're wrong I think the
first step though is helping your
brother recognize that he has anger
problems yeah that's if he doesn't
accept that and understand it then you
know it's he's gonna have a long road
ahead yeah like people have to just
understand like yeah they're there cuz
then it's gonna turn into awareness like
if you don't understand that you have it
and accept it then you can't be aware of
it yeah so but you gotta do it in a very
sensitive way because what if you guys
are fighting and then you go oh you have
[ __ ] anger issues like that's the
wrong time yeah you can't do that and
you gotta figure find out like an
appropriate chill place to do it - yeah
it's it's weird because I have a
relative right now who in in the family
he's he's the he's considered the calm
nice one right but because we all grew
up in a similar household he's actually
dealing with the same anger issues that
I had when I was growing up and because
he was such a nice person on an exterior
level and now that he's in a very
serious relationship he's he's
expressing the type of anger that that
all of us are growing up in in our
households and I'm seeing it now and you
know he was telling me a story how he
got into an argument with his girlfriend
right now and you know his his anger was
warranted right and he was she
understands why he was angry because she
she kind of messed up but how he dealt
with it was kind of how I would used to
deal with stuff right [ __ ] yeah I never
thought that he would have had those
problems and so for him he was just
saying it like he was normal like I did
I was trying to normalize it yeah and so
he was telling me yeah I got really mad
that I punched the wall punch the hole
in the wall and stuff that's your
signature move yeah that's the Davis so
gotta hit something move and then I told
them I was like yo you know that's not
healthy like you can't every time you
get angry you can't just break [ __ ]
because it makes you feel that way you
know and I told him - I was like you go
by the way you go out with the [ __ ]
white girl she's not used to that [ __ ]
she grew up in a very fake they talk
their problems out specifically the hurt
type of white very astute like she grew
up in a very normal household as I call
it you know they they talk out their
problems and so
you do that stuff to her I guarantee you
maybe she hasn't said it to you but
you're scaring the living [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of her and not only that she's she's
gonna she's gonna look at you very small
she's gonna put you down to that
pedestal she's gonna look at you like
I'm with a [ __ ] child yeah and that's
the last thing you want your partner to
do is look at you as an insignificant
piece of [ __ ] yeah and dude that's
that's the opposite like what you want
man like I don't know it's true though
we just we've normalized things because
our culture right like I'm sure this
person asking might be Asian or whatever
yeah and in our culture it's kind of
like you [ __ ] up for making your dad
mad you [ __ ] up for making that person
mad yeah cuz I've always taught to like
fix it before it happens yeah yeah and
it can't be like that people have to
communicate but I think the first step
is to try to get your brother in a space
where he doesn't feel attacked and let
them know like dude it is [ __ ]
hurtful when you get angry it's scary
yeah cuz it makes me not you know want
to open up and be close to you because
I'm afraid of you yeah cuz getting angry
at somebody for their anger problems
with powerbi they'll probably be the
worst thing that you could do it happens
a lot yeah because people feel hurt and
so they just want to tell people like
dude you got problems what's wrong with
you that's the worst way to approach
somebody but you have to treat them like
we go something's defected about you
because you have these problems [ __ ] you
like they feel justified like yeah I'm a
betting and her brother's eyes like when
he's upset about something that he rages
out yeah he's like I have my every right
to be this mad mmm right yeah I feel
like that's probably a lot of it too so
being able to kind of shift that focus
to to seeing the pro would imagine that
making that your brother see that how
hurtful he's being when he is that way
like you said is probably probably the
most effective way for him to handle
that situation especially if if he felt
like he was wrong like like [ __ ] you
stole my Pokemon cards I remember that
[ __ ] yeah you know it's like I'm gonna
[ __ ] he could chew away from me
you know and then like he's all mad
about that and he's it's like well if
you're the culprit of his of whatever it
is like if you're the bad guy in his
head first step is to not be the bad guy
how do you do that you got to you got to
figure out a common ground you got to
find that bridge you got to find that
way to connect back and be an ally be a
friend and then not make it about hey
your aim your anger is just out of
control I need to fix it right now you
got to be like you know it's more like
it hurts me when you're angry but I'm
your sister and I want to help you
mm-hmm so that takes a really tough
person yeah because it's almost like
while you're [ __ ] using me as a
punching bag I want to [ __ ] hold you
close that's hard to do you have to be
very empathetic in that point of view
you have to come from a place of like
hey I care I want to see you not go
through something like this but it is
really tough because you have to be like
a way quote-unquote bigger person though
yeah Jen right that is the bigger person
solving your problems with words are
hard sometimes I want to get this rock
and just chuck it in somebody's face and
it is that way easier this is if you if
you piss be a ho there's a rock in your
face sometimes you have to look at
people like they're crazy and you just
have to be like oh how do you talk a
crazy person exactly you you can't like
like you said like well be aging out
mm-hmm you can't argue with them you
have to say mm-hmm all right cool I see
you're upset
whatever I'm out here I'm gone you have
your space to kind of vent because
especially when someone meets you with
like that type of energy and you give
them the oh okay and you walk away and
you don't really give them any reaction
because a lot of times too I feel like
when you're upset and you're and you're
like a raging out you're looking for a
reaction to like for instance when I'm
driving and I [ __ ] flip out this is
the place I'm thinking about it from
when I flip the [ __ ] out cuz someone
almost hit me I'm trying to pull up to
the dude and I know I'm being crazy
but I feel one I feel justified too
I want to see this [ __ ]
acknowledge me yeah to be like yo you
[ __ ] this is how you're making me
feel right now
come from the person that's like being
angered right which is very crazy yeah
right it's insane but I know I have that
like issue and I have to like kind of
bury it down as a dear old lady you're
like yeah you feel that way yeah you
better should even have a license you
[ __ ] yeah get on here then exactly
corpse double driving but when they
don't acknowledge you and they it kind
of makes me feel like when I get really
mad around TIFF or something like that
she just goes okay and then just goes
away and then I feel like yeah I'm being
crazy okay and I'm like I'm being a
child right now because I'm just acting
out because I want this person to see
that like I'm [ __ ] mad yeah knowledge
that I'm mad you know this podcast is
brought to you by Boombah Boombah
Boombah as my friends
do you remember what the cool thing was
when you were in school oh I do
it was pokemon cards and them gel pens
son gel pens brought thugs and little
cute little Keroppi asian girls all
together whether you were tagging up a
wall tagging up your paper or you were
just doing home or like a sane human
being gel pens were the cool thing to do
well guess what nowadays people its
bomba socks if you're in it then you
know and if you didn't well guess what
sucks for you because bomba socks are
all the envy in the schoolyard which
isn't really all that surprising because
they're the most comfortable kids socks
ever they're colorful literally bursting
with color they even have a cute little
beyond them and comfortable my friends
comfort is the key because they're
designed with several comfort
innovations that make them feel better
than any other kids sock ever made so
send your kids back to school with the
socks that keep them comfy colorful and
ready to take on the school year and
since bum Boz donates a pair of socks
for every pair purchase you should get
one yourself - I wear bombas every day
if these feet are not bare they got
bomba socks on them son
that's all I grace my toes and my
cuticles with in your face visit bo
moz.com slash brain and get 20% off your
purchase that's Bo MBA Escom slash brain
for 20% off your first purchase bombas
comm slash brain how dare you yell at
tissue sweetest thing I don't I don't
know if you guys ask
I don't yell too but then when you're
throwing
aggressive energy and you're angry
that's when she treats you that way
she goes okay or if I raise my voice
like a decibel over the line she's
sensitive to that she could tell yeah
cuz usually I don't I'm not like I with
her specifically I truly try not to get
crazy I try not to like get upset I try
to just say all right I try to be as
calm as possible
I really do Wow then if I get we're a
better fighter yeah if I just go up and
just a little bit then I'm used to she
goes oh you [ __ ] no don't even
she's like don't even cuz I know for my
dad he has a very he has a really high
temper and went in a household where you
see that kind of go off yeah I really
try hard to be like I don't want that
for my family or my living area and I
want to bring that type of energy around
you know just because you know that like
okay it doesn't create some issues I
know how it affects my family my sisters
whatever so in my head I'm like okay
this is no-go
this can never happen so I tried really
hard to like not let that happen
and when I do I feel like [ __ ] I let
something very small cuz it's an issue
that doesn't really matter and get the
better of me and make me a react in a
certain way where I go [ __ ] I'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm in a piece of me I
think that's why I mean we've talked
about this too it's very important for
people to have a group of friends around
them so it could just blow off steam to
them instead of partners it doesn't mean
that you're whining and complaining you
just some people just they just need
somebody there to talk to yeah right and
you know if you have a good group of
people around you to they if they are
that close they they'll listen very well
or if they're acting dumb they'll be
like hey why don't you see it this way
too because that happens a lot in our
cases too yeah there was a point where
just we would just eat some Japanese
food and [ __ ] about our ladies and that
that was like on a JK news day we were
we're basically talking already from
8:00 to like 10:00 p.m. so we're already
talking all day but we have this extra
energy
I still need a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
I got complaining to do yeah this is the
only person that understand my walls
because we both were dating similar
people there at the same time
and both of us were progressing in a
relationship very like yeah kind of like
at the same time too so like we kind of
related and understood each other a lot
of going literally through the same [ __ ]
at the same time yeah
you just you just went past me yeah and
I was stuck in a certain stage and like
it did feel better to work out the [ __ ]
and deal with it with you but the
problem that I had was I wasn't really
evolving so that was like it was getting
out of my system but nothing was fit
like working out in my relationship so
that was a huge one you know but but
then yeah it did help if I didn't have
that I don't think I would have been
with Jess for sure - cuz if I didn't
have those moments where I got to just
hash out what I wanted to say that I
that we couldn't really communicate
because after we did that she and I were
allowed to talk about it afterwards and
then either joke about it or just just
run back to it right because also to the
person that was there Gio was there too
and then she had her female perspective
which kind of helped us out that's very
important - yeah cause if it's just a
bunch of dudes sometimes sometimes we
just do we just we're just griping and
sometimes what girls - I call it the hen
house they just [ __ ] clucking yeah
but if they don't have good friends
whether it's guys or girls they implant
really bad ideas into you you know they
don't think the best of your men or
anything and they they they implant some
jealous crazy ideas yeah you're it's
really important to have friends that
are like making you think the other side
of the other point yeah instead of like
are you sure she's not cheating on you
right now that's why she's acting dude
like there's [ __ ] like that out
that's true do you then you're just like
oh my god and they only do that because
they don't like to see people happy
they're instigators yeah do you know
about that do you have a situation with
that - oh yeah dude this [ __ ]
dude we went to a party and this is
before me and TIFF
got engaged and this one girl that I've
never met before and she was talking to
TIFF like yeah your man needs to be
she's like how long you guys been
together TIFF goes about eight years
eight and a half years and she goes man
your man needs to propose to you
bah blah blah blah cuz you're beautiful
you can go get any man you want
[ __ ] and she's like he's being lazy
he's sitting on his ass yada yada yada
yada and like just going off and I was
like dude I've never met her like ever
and she was going off and apparently
she's going through some [ __ ] with her
man or whatever but she's just venting
yeah ejected the event if was like
saying this stuff to me and I was like
that [ __ ] [ __ ] I was like that's so
- even know who you are
no oh no all she was you've been
together eight years and then she goes
off dude she was we wrapped the same
party together we're like Tiffany was
sitting with the girls sitting down over
here and I was like talking to my
buddies around the side and she just
saying all the stuff and I was like and
I got home and she was telling me about
it and like TIFF was kind of buying into
it and I was like you [ __ ] say you
should know better
into it she goes she goes it's just so
funny how she was saying all this stuff
and she kept bringing it up and I was
like no that's not funny
yeah that's not funny at all I will
round you I mean it man I was like what
do you do I feel backstabbed like don't
even entertain that [ __ ] Vaughn should
be closer than a [ __ ] stranger
implants negativity issue and I was like
did you say do you defend me and then
she was like yeah I got and I was like
all right cool that's not [ __ ] matter
it's but it's it's projection cuz she's
looking by the way lady I don't know who
you are but how's your broken up
relationship you you [ __ ] [ __ ] bag Oh
G alright I don't know her but I just
hate people like that don't put your
[ __ ] negative vibes onto somebody
else's healthy relationship she's also
she was probably drunk too so you know
perfect it just goes to show your
alcoholic and your dumbest oh my god
David do what have I met her absolutely
not but see how that works how I didn't
meet you when I'm making up some
assumptions it was my sister it was my
sister she was the one time he will [ __ ]
your sister alright which one the one
that I met her didn't matter it was it
wasn't neither of them but either way if
it wasn't one I didn't meet [ __ ] her too
man oh man I know taking everyone yeah
by the way if I do meet you though I
take this all back yeah yeah I'm sorry
here great you're part of the Dunn clan
I forgive you but it's also crazy too is
like when you sometimes if you're an
argument with a screaming other and then
you like bring it up to your buddies or
something and they look at you and they
go that's stupid yeah they're like why
are you mad about that
well I've in your head you're like oh
[ __ ] that is dumb or you say it out loud
and you know you don't need anyone else
to say anything but you realize like
yeah you cannot
sometimes I see symbolism like if I see
similarities and other people's
relationships and I'm like oh look I do
that yeah yeah that helps a lot too yeah
oh man I'm a [ __ ] stubborn
[ __ ] I better go home and say
sorry but none of that [ __ ] could ever
happen unless you're like self-aware and
that takes time yeah like so there's a
recipe right like first is awareness or
first is like agreeing that you have a
problem second is trying to be aware so
every time it comes up you go oh yeah I
did get angry I did get angry then you
could start to control it a little bit
by figuring out ways to express it
without being damaging yeah and on top
of that like the recipe for good good
friendship to that's really important
you mean you don't evolve if you don't
have people to bounce back ideas with
and if you don't see other people going
through the same [ __ ] you're doing
because then that will help you
recognize like ah that's what I do I do
that [ __ ] you know but then when you're
blinded because you you have pride you
have ego you have all these things
you're in denial yeah and if people
don't even understand that they have
something called an ego now ego just
doesn't mean being conceited an ego is a
part of your personality that doesn't
want to be wrong because it likes to
stay safe it's it's it's a protection
mechanism for human survival yeah and
back in the day you know like it's it's
something that helped us live
comfortably because you make sense of
the world and you're like you think you
know what's going on and you don't want
to be wrong because it's very
uncomfortable to be wrong mm-hmm so in
order for us to break through and evolve
as human beings you have to recognize
that that's there and it's constantly
fighting to be right yeah and sometimes
those belief systems like whatever you
think is right
is damaging to you and you don't know it
so there's a huge disconnect and I
forgive a lot of people because a lot of
people live a life unaware they just do
not know they're just living and they're
just breathing and they're talking and
they're reacting and they do not know
that a lot of these things are happening
and they're living in [ __ ] turmoil
yeah yeah that that that's why I think
it goes back to us saying that
acknowledgement is really important it
has to really hit you hard yeah that's
the sink and you literally have to see
it for yourself because you know we were
also talking about just that's why it's
very important to get them in a state
where their mind is very stable yeah cuz
how is it gonna sink in like Mariel
could have told me a million times over
that I had anger issues but I in my mind
I was rationalizing it well you actually
have [ __ ] issues so I am I exist if I
wasn't around you making moves like that
I I would rationalize it somehow so
that's funny cuz you think me breaking
[ __ ] is a problem I think you getting me
to the point where I'm breaking [ __ ] is
a problem that's a you problem [ __ ] oh
yeah not a me problem you you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I love you I never by the way I've
never loved you I've never ever called
Mariola [ __ ] ever in my [ __ ] life by
the way these are all just jokes yeah
yeah same same two tissues listen yeah
that's that's a fact you could ask I'll
bring on this podcast just so she could
say that by the way yeah I'm just a
tough guy on mic call Jess a [ __ ]
multiple times and I'm not I am NOT
[ __ ] proud of ya
dude I I feel guilty whole civ but you
know what like we have this relationship
to like if it's not with ill intent like
we have we're very in tune I realize
because when she's insulting me with
negative intent it hurts me and I'm mad
but she could say the same exact thing
she could call me fat twenty [ __ ]
times but if it's without negative
intent I'm laughing with her yeah like
in Japan her my mom had a roast fest for
a whole day just calling me fat making
fat jokes long [ __ ] day and I loved
it because they were bonding and it's
like hilarious really I like how you
guys can bond over my pancakes guys
appreciate it all right it's it's
totally different but then there's this
time that she did call me but but it's
like we just had an argument and she
knows I'm in place as a weapon yeah yeah
and then
you know there's just things like like
like I called her [ __ ] as it like like
you know how like we call the girls
[ __ ] some jazz it like you my [ __ ]
like we're pretending to be like one of
them and [ __ ] you know like girl what's
up [ __ ] you know and that's cool
because there's no they know what it
means
yeah so I don't think words are really
out of boundary it's like what are you
packaging that word with yeah
are you packaging it with hate or love
context it is context and that time and
place thing is super important because
it also reflects on well what is the
status of our relationship right now if
things are [ __ ] Rocky that joking
[ __ ] is not gonna go very well right now
for sure not gonna call you [ __ ] now
yeah but just wait til we're healthy
yeah yeah [ __ ] all over the coz I mean
like if you're going to your friend's
funeral and then like you're like hey
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] my grandma died show
[ __ ] up right that's my uncle for sure
but if they're really cool they'll be
like what up [ __ ] like I said right
back to you
my uncle is though is time and place is
something that he really doesn't
understand this fool is like trying to
crack jokes at my grandma's funeral not
even a [ __ ] joke dude this guy's just
as my grandma is being put into the
grave he goes as he look he's looking at
this mechanism that's putting her in the
grave he goes that's pretty handy huh
you see his son why cuz it go dead shut
the [ __ ] up so mad dude that's how some
people cope so my roommate right his
brother he copes with comedy a lot so
like they're their grandpa I think there
was a Guilder grandpa's funeral right
and it was really sad and shitty Andy
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] up and so it
was his grandpa's funeral his dad it was
his turn to go see his father right so
he goes hook to his casket so his dad
goes to the casket and my friend's
brother goes advances his dad while he's
looking at the casket your [ __ ] life
are you serious
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you know what a good idea that idea what
[Laughter]
this episode started off so what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] my wildest dreams would
never think about
he's always pranking and [ __ ] the whole
congregation should've beat his ass
I was Bob he lost his father it's not
like it wasn't like it was his dad that
passed right no just grandpa his dad
will see crying before he got his pants
but before he got passed I don't know
all you just tell me what he did he's
like he's such a [ __ ] idiot but
everybody still laughing about food
that's crazy
he just think I got a light in the movie
but like some people they handle their
pain with comedy dude I'm the same way
man [ __ ] I hope things but I would never
imagine you doing something like that
dude that was just on that got something
out of a [ __ ] movie well I hope
finale man Spotify iTunes give us that
five star on iTunes and then we will see
you guys next time do a Nick what can
they find you you find me Nick the ear
on the.com on Instagram and on YouTube
all right chatter nothing matters that
you can find us at funerals pants
[Laughter]